russia is starting joint military drills
with its neighbor belarus today nato
says it is moscow's largest deployment
to the former soviet country since the
cold war the exercises come as tensions
build over what some western countries
fear are russian plans to invade ukraine
diplomacy is continuing but the u.s has
criticized the new joint military drills
as escalatory kiev says these are about
psychological pressure russia claims the
forces will return to their bases when
the drills finish in 10 days time
the u.s is also deploying more troops to
eastern europe as a show of solidarity
they're bolstering nato's borders
on wednesday u.s troops arrived in
southeastern poland
the united states has also begun moving
its forces from germany to romania
around a thousand nato troops are
expected to follow in the coming days
denmark has also announced that it's
enhancing its military preparedness
deploying fighter jets to the baltic sea
but many western analysts do not see
nato's actions in response to the more
than 100 000 russian troops amassed near
ukraine's borders as a direct defense of
ukraine now in terms of numbers this is
meant to be a symbolic show of resolve
that the
nato is united and it will defend its
members if attacked for ukraine we've
provided arms and training but we're not
providing any direct forces nobody is
further consignments of british weapons
have arrived in ukraine
britain has said it only intends them to
be used in self-defense
speaking in berlin on wednesday german
chancellor olaf schultz said a dual
approach was needed adding that while
all diplomatic channels must be pursued
allies must be prepared to act if
russian forces cross these borders and
into ukraine
for more perspective on the story we can
speak now to carl belt he is the
co-chair of the european council of
foreign relations and former prime
minister of sweden mr belt welcome tdw i
want to start with a russia's military
drills russia says these drills are for
its own security ukraine says this is
psychological pressure do you think that
these drills are a further escalation of
the situation
they are clearly one part of the very
major military buildup that we've seen
from the russian side during the last
few months and it is still ongoing apart
from this maneuvers in belarus we have a
significant concentration of russian
forces along the borders of ukraine and
is the largest such buildup of military
forces that we've seen in in europe for
decades we have to go way back into the
cold war to say anything like this
i want to ask you now about nato's
response to all of this we saw the
secretary general ian stoltenberg
speaking at a news conference a short
while ago let's uh play first of all
what he said and then talk about it
let's listen in
this is a dangerous moment for european
security
the number of russian forces is going up
the warning time for a possible attack
is going down
nato is not a threat to russia
but we must be prepared for the worst
while remaining strongly committed to
finding a political solution
mr bilt we heard yen stoltenberg say
this is preparing for the worst from the
perspective of nato and you wrote
recently on twitter it is a good sign
that germany for example is upping its
contribution to the nato battalion and
lithuania because this is a reassurance
in uncertain times but still these nato
forces pale in comparison to what russia
has been preparing so does this really
act as a deterrent to russia
i think the main deterrent is as a
matter of fact the preparations that are
done for very significant sanctions by
the eu and and by the u.s in case
there's another russian innovation of uh
ukraine uh those sanctions have been and
that's the ongoing process coordinated
between washington and brussels and then
coordinated between brussels and the
different member states
and uh the way i understand it uh they
would be very significant and have a
very significant effect on the russian
economy and hopefully that will serve as
a deterrent so that uh there is no
further incursions and invasions of
ukraine but we don't know
but there has been some disagreement
among western allies of what those
sanctions should be
do you think that europe's reliance on
russian gas is serving as a liability at
this point
i think it's clearly a problem um and i
think there is an awareness
all over europe i think even in germany
that long term there would be sort of a
need to reduce that reliance on russian
gas because it provides russia with
leverage in political situations like
this then replacement of that can't
happen overnight
but i think over years absolutely i
think that needs to be
a redirection of
energy dependence
i want to ask you about the west putting
its hopes on the long stuck mince
agreement that was first negotiated in
2014 and 2015.
ukrainian officials say that this peace
deal itself is a weapon that moscow is
using to try to destroy their country
what is your assessment
well
if you take the russian interpretation
of it absolutely
then the russians are trying to use the
minsk agreement to that particular
effect that is not going to be accepted
by
kiev obviously
it is an agreement that isn't entirely
clear there's a rather dubious element
of it and there has been a significant
disagreement between moscow and kiev on
the timing of it on local elections and
special status and who's going to
control the borders so it's a very sort
of uh
it wasn't drafted with too much of it
just precision and that is used by
moscow very much in order to
impose upon ukraine a version of the
minsk agreement that is clearly
detrimental to the security interests of
the country that's resisted
by kiev understandably so
i want to ask you last of all mr bilt
about the fact that the german
chancellor olaf schultz has said he is
hopeful
that there can be good progress made
particularly this week on finding a
diplomatic solution to this crisis as
things stand at the moment with these
military drills taking place uh from the
russian side today the response from
ukraine are you confident that there is
still an avenue for a diplomatic
solution
well
i would agree with the chancellor that
one should be hopeful but but one should
also be really realistic i mean it's
good that sort of berlin and paris is
now sort of accelerating efforts on
donbass on the means process but we
should understand that the russian game
at the moment is much bigger uh donbass
is a sideshow i have to say the russian
game if you listen to mr putin and see
the documents that they've put on the
table is about ukraine as a whole and
it's about sort of changing the entire
european security order and that is a
negotiation that they undertaken
primarily with
the us and with nato that's the big game
that we see at the moment
we'll have to leave it there carl bill
the co-chair of the european council
foreign relations former prime minister
of sweden thank you very much for
joining us
thank you
you